Au départ, les fleurs de pissenlit sont jaunes,
mais ça ne dure que quelques jours.
Très vite elles se transforment
et finissent par ressembler
à une boule de coton extrêmement fragile.
En fait, la tige de pissenlit ne porte pas une fleur,
mais une multitude de fleurons
qui produisent chacun une graine.
Alors évidemment, le grand jeu c’est de souffler…
Chaque graine est suspendue à une touffe de poils,
une aigrette.
Des chercheurs d’Edimbourg au Royaume-Uni
ont récemment découvert que grâce à sa forme particulière et son nombre de poils,
toujours le même,
un tourbillon se forme au-dessus de l’aigrette,
une dépression qui va ralentir
considérablement la chute de la graine.
De cette manière, transportée par le vent,
elle peut parcourir jusqu’à, tenez-vous bien,
une centaine de kilomètres…
Une vrai « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez on recommence ?
Bye-bye...
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur la gauche.
J’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
et pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés et on reste en lien.